[Musique]
35% des français reste récalcitrants
vaccin ne veulent pas se faire vacciner
sauf que pour atteindre limité mais il
faut 90 % des français selon l'institut
pasteur
non le vaccin contre le coc vide ne
contient pas de puce électronique qui
rend le corps magnétique
n'en déplaise aux internautes qui use de
stratagèmes pour tenter de le prouver
la théorie farfelue suicide des
moqueries mais là la vie dure nick
machine révolte porte d'auteuil il était
22h 45 hier soir à roland garros lorsque
le speaker conformément aux dispositions
gouvernementales a demandé aux
spectateurs de quitter la tribune et de
regagner leur hôtel particulier du 16e
arrondissement
nouveau rappel 15 minutes plus tard
réponse du public
[Applaudissements]
de mémoire de yorkshire jamais leurs
maîtres n'avaient pas réussi courroucé
neuilly auteuil passy c'est pas du
gâteau quand il s'agit de défendre
passing shot lifté service gagnant notre
chauffeur en fait quand on rentre en
france
hélas pour moi ma pour les déplacements
il est là pour m'aider bas ne serait ce
qu'à piquer la poussette m'aider à
porter la petite c'est quand même une
grande est la ville femme de footballeur
je pense qu'on a beaucoup davantage on
va pas se mentir lavier assez facile
m lundi dernier gosia mme tamara sithole
a accouché de dix bébés 5 par voie
naturelle 5 par césarienne le papa
explique qu à l'échographie on ne voyait
que huit foetus à y aurait donc eu deux
bébés bonus au dernier moment
résultat des courses selon le papa ce
sont sept garçons et trois filles
pour l'instant les autorités sud
africaines n'ont pas encore confirmé
officiellement mais le guinness book est
déjà sur place pour enquêter sur le cas
de cette maman
[Musique]
magnifique qui a pris 10 ans dans la
tête que chrétien je ne peux pas me
livrer à aucune violence
ensuite j'ai un autre projet artistique
c'est je vais signer ça c'est de la
violence
ça c'est de la violence vous rigolez pas
c'est rigolo
sauf que vous aussi vous êtes dieu merci
francis ça c'est de la vraie violence
alors ensuite
ensuite j'ai un autre projet artistique
d'un autre projet artistique
oh oui merci mon corps j'ai toujours
voulu être ce connard avec sa guitare au
camping au feu mais tu ne m'étais déjà
comme un événement le trio c'est ross
[Musique]
je sais pas alors je t'avoue je vais la
brader complet et cei mr y là j'ai perdu
sur cela tout à fait ouais tu veut
lâcher sa main droite
j'avais à fait ça anto le pose là pas de
chance rhinocéros est trop trop dur même
c'est un mot qu'on n'emploie jamais
andré joseph un bouclier yonne famille
célèbre de dompteur à peut-être trouvé
la solution pour présenter les animaux
sans nuire au bien-être animal
autour de lui et à faire pareil et
laguna boulevard ressortir
[Musique]
un groupe de quinze éléphants qui s'est
enfui d'une réserve naturelle du
sud-ouest de la chine pour migrer vers
le nord du pays alors ils ont déjà
parcouru 500 km depuis avril on sait pas
pourquoi
et leur migration c'est un mystère
c'est un hologramme d'ours polaires
complètement numérique
il va chanter donc le désir d origine
qui est une chanson composée
spécialement pour lui qui reste steve
mais qui raconte l'histoire d'aude de
dan ours qui qu'elle désire de rugir et
caen qui en a marre de de faire du
spectacle et convient juste de retourner
à l'état sauvage
léo ferré a été mon maître et mon ami
pendant 15 ans et plus avant de mourir
il avait projeté d'enregistrer un album
et que cet album il n'a pas pu
l'enregistrer parce qu'il est mort ça
c'est horrible c'est pas moi j'écoute
oui de vous écouter ce que vous pouvez
laisser votre portable des clefs je suis
connecté non les gens ne supportent pas
que vous regardiez les genres jab
en fait tous les jours je suis obligé de
faire le même temps l'école c'est pas
respectueux pour les gens qui nous
écoutent surfer sur internet limiterait
aussi notre capacité à comprendre et à
retenir ce qu'on vit ce car
contrairement à la lecture linéaire d'un
livre la lecture sur internet nous
oblige à prendre sans cesse des
décisions doivent cliquer et j'ai envie
de voir cette vidéo où cette publicité
toutes ces sollicitations perturbe notre
concentration et qui dit voir une
concentration dit potentiellement moins
de mémorisation et j'étais en train de
parler de la mort d'un grand succès ah
oui ça peut être bien aussi à ce moment
là que tu m'écoutes des coûts au lieu de
rire au moment où je parle de la mort de
quelqu'un écoute les gens fous rires
c'est bon c'est la dernière angles et
donc tu vas tu vas faire un album
aujourd'hui c'est très compliqué parce
que quand on a un minimum instruits on
passe pour le google de service alors
que pas du tout bien au contraire on les
manipule tous sont nés les plus
intelligents aujourd'hui dans le monde
on se fie beaucoup aux apparences j'ai
jamais manger des gâteaux de litière de
genre
challans chasse à celle là je m'y
attendais pas dis moi tu arrêter de
fumer mais tu avais arrêté de picoler
c'est en cours vous êtes trop bon
kim se la joue calimero ou kim libéraux
pour le coup et voilà rattrapé il
faudrait des mots réconfortants
david vous avez sens noc récolte ce
qu'on sème voit la famille de la mère de
ben tu récoltes de cacao
tu les a bien réussi les p tits à calais
péter à mais je veux dire c'est pas
facile moi je ne serais pas capable
d'aller faire des quatre cas pas on
n'est pas en train de parler de ça le
métier quoi vite que quand tu vois quand
tu fais une journée comme ça ouais t'es
heureux des situations que tu t'es quand
même rendu utile tu vois moi construit
une journée comme ça